大家好,我是Yumi,那今天呢,咱们又将迎来一场聚焦基金智能投研全场景这样一个深度解析的主题分享,那今天呢,也非常荣幸的邀请到我的好朋友,那咱们火腹牛的产品总监蔡强老师,为大家带来火腹牛基金智能投研的全场景这样的一个主题分享,带大家了解就是这个服务于近千家机构的智能投研平台,那如何重构FORF投资与财富管理的工作流。
那像咱们蔡强老师呢
也是深耕金融科技领域
与量化私募行业很多年了
那目前呢负责火腹牛平台的
整体产品规划和全流程落地运营
那接下来呢
我就先把时间交给我们的蔡强老师
蔡老师
好的感谢英烈老师的一个推荐
那么也感谢大家下午的时间
那么我这边就简单介绍一下
我们平台主要的一些核心的一个功能点
那么为了本次演示呢
所以说我这边也是虚拟的很多数据
那么我接下来所共享屏幕这边的很多一些视目镜子
包括一些可能一些估值表信息等
那么这些都是我相关的一个演示的数据
那么不代表管理人的真实的一个情况
那么首先就简单介绍一下我们平台的一个产品背景
那么火火牛的基金投赢平台
其实从2017年18年就开始着手立项去开发了
那最开始的话呢
我们是给一些管理人
一些服务投资系统的一个定制化的开发
那么近些年来
我们也是保持着
每个月的一个版本的一个更新迭代
那目前基本上能够满足
我们资管端
尤其是一些直白金融机构
那么他这样一些
服务投资相关的这样的一些需求点
那么另外呢
也围绕着这样一些财务端
比如说我们的理财师
我们的基金的一些投资顾问
那么可能也需要这样的一个平台
进行一些经济分析
经济对比等这些核心的一个功能点
那么下面呢
我就按照我们大概的一个
功能菜单走起
那么简单去聊一下我们每一个
功能菜单下面
主要的一个服务的一个场景
分别是什么
那首先呢这是一个市场大的
一个模块
那么这里面的话呢我们收录了很多
一些金融市场环境变让的数据
能够帮助大家了解一下
比如当前的一些股票阿尔法
以及说一些商品的一些市场
那么期权的市场
它大概的一些策略的一个运行环境
比如说股票这边来的
我们收入一些金融市场这样一些指标
比如说一些升贴水率
一些成交额换手率
包括估值水平
一些持续货截面的波动率
等这样一些情况
能够帮助大家了解一下
当前的这样一些股票量化的
一个运行的一个情况
那第二个是一些商品市场的话
我们这边有收入一些商品指数
会进行一些指数的一些分析
指数的这样一些
时序或截面的波动率
以及说一些商品市场的振幅跳开
包括一些趋势或截面的
一个challenge跟踪的情况
能够帮助我们了解一下
量化CT的一个表现的
一些市场环境指标
那后面是一些期权的一些市场
我们这边有堆一些基础标的
它这样一些市场情绪指标
另外有一些PCR的分析
和一些紧波IV的
这样的分析情况
能够帮助了解一下
期权的这样一些运行的策略环境
那么第二个是一个分割因子
这里面呢
我们有构建了一套期货的一个分割因子
那么也有一个股票
拜尔的生一五跟生一六
这样一套分割因子
那么有了这些分割因子
我们就可以把这些因子的表现
跟我们拭目镜的一些镜子
拭目镜的估值表进行一个绩效归因
那这是一个分割因子的相关的一些
界面或实际的表现的一个分析
那么下方呢
还有一个就是一个策略观察
因为我们这个平台
其实也是深耕私募领域多年了
所以说我们对于全市场
那么这些私募管理人
他们都在做什么策略
那么每一个策略里面
这样一些代表产品
都有哪些也都比较熟悉
所以说我们这边有构建好
这样一些私募的一个表现
那个样本分析
那么您可以在顶部这边来勾选
相关这样一些私募样本之后
我们这边会每周等权
那么计算一下
那么比如说股票市场中心呢
那么它从2018年以来
每一周每一月
它对应了这样一些绝对收益率
或者说一些指针的这样
超过收益率表现的情况
我们可以通过这个模块
清晰的知道说
当前的某些失贸策略
那么它在历史上的某一周的
一个表现的情况
同时我们对于这样一个策略样本
也会做个你和分部的分析
那么也会做一下
我们某一个指标的这样一个氛围分析
比如说股标市场中心的
我们可以知道说
它在近一年的一个均值
前时氛围中位数水平
到后时氛围的表现的情况
那这是一个私募的一个次率观察
那下方呢
还有一个比较大家关注的功能点
就是一个私募指数
我们这边不仅有
否固扭的一套私募指数
我们这边也有跟其他的
这样一些平台
比如像国联期货
招商托管
国在海中托管
等这样一些机构
那么他们有编织好私募指数了
也在这边进行一个展示
那么这些私募指数
都可以作为我们在做基金分析
基金对比的时候
可以选为基准
可以做一个策略表现的
这样一个参考值
那这是一个市场
这样一个大的一个模块
那第二个模块
就是这边有一个基金数据库
那首先是一个私募的
这样一套数据库
那么我们这边收录了
全网所有的这样一些
私募证据类的基金
包含一些指管产品
信托产品和公务专户
等这样的一些产品列表
我们把它归类到
这个私募基金
这个大的列表
那么在这里面的话
我们提供非常丰富的
一个筛选
比如说一些
策略的一个筛选
包括一些基金属性
跟管理人属性
或者说一些基金指标
这样的筛选
能够帮助我们进行
投钱的这样一些基金筛选
这样一些需求
那么同时的话
我们跟很多管理人
进行一个数据的一个授权
作为合作认证之后
那么国安联把净值从托管
发送到我们这个平台
我们把这个数据展示给我们
这样一些机构的合同投资者
进行这样一个基金分析和基金对比
那下方呢
还有说一个比较完善的一套
国立的一套公募的这样一个数据库
包括说一些ETF的数据库
也就是说一些海外的
这样一些基金的这样一个数据库
我们都可以把这样一些公募
跟私募产品进行对比
进行分析
那另外一个层面
就是我们这边
也收录了很多一些指数
我们跟中正南华
深圳万能
这样一个指数公司
进行授权之后
把这些指数
进行一个收录好
然后我们可以进行
指数的这样一些分析
那这是一个基金储备库
那第三个菜单
是一个严选
这个大的一个模块
这里面主要是一个
师目周报
我们的研究员
会把全市场
这样一些策略的
这样一些产品
进行一个分类
比如说像CTA这边
我们进行这样一些
精选之后
选择一些比较有代表的这样一些产品
把它进行一个周报的一个跟踪
那包含CTA的包含股票对冲的
那么一些Alpha的
以及说一些套利的期权的
和多资产宏观等这样一些策略
大概有几百个产品
那么用户可以通过这个模块
能够比较清晰快速的知道说
上一周那么这些失误的表现的情况
那另外一个就是说
这边有一个进调的
一个报告的一个功能
我们的研究员
每周会去写一些管理人尽量报告
会更新出来
那么帮助重复了解一下
那么这个管理人
那么他都是做什么策略的
那每个策略的一些细节
包括一些代表产品的表现情况
那等这样一个情况
我们会进行一个尽量报告
和进行一些分享和导出
那第四个菜单就是
这边有一个组合这个功能
因为有很多时候呢
我们的FORWO研究员
或者我们FORWO的基金经理
那么他们需要进行一些
资产配置方案的一个输出
所以说我们这边有提供相关这样一些模型
比如说像自定义权重
或者等权军事方差
MV BL等这样一些模型
能够帮助我们进行一个组合方案的一个构建
我们可以选择一些产品
那么基于这些模型
那么定义好一些约束条件之后
比如说它这样一些相关这样一些
优异化目标
包括一些预期的这样一些收益赋源
计算区间等这些指标
包括一些再平衡设置
我们就可以进行一些组合的一个模拟
甚至说我们对于私募基金
可以设一下业绩暴走公式
可以进行废后的这样一个模拟
那么另外一个组合就是说
私房组合
那么顾名思义就是说
我们在投后
可能有一些相关的这样一些
申购 赎回 分红
我们这样一些流水了
我们可以基于这个流水
进行组合的构建
帮主们分析我们这个投资的
这样一个组合
它的表现是什么样的
包括说一些里程的
这样一些收益拆解
都可以进行实现
这是一个组合的这样一套功能点
那第五个就是投资这个大的一个模块了
那么这个模块的话
其实我们是按照我们投资的一个三个场景
比如说我们可能先去尽调某个管理人
那么在尽调之前
我们可能也会有一个尽调日程的一个安排
我们这边有一个新增日程
你可以通过这个功能
帮助我们把一些尽调的这些日历进行一个管理
可以进行汇总
那么尽调之后呢
我们可以进行一个报告的一个输出
我们可以按照这个报告模板
把这样一些录音的情况
给它进行整理之后
形成一个尽量报告
那么在建掉之后
如果说这个产品或者这个管理人
那么他需要上会了
需要入池了
然后有些机构可能需要进行打一个分数
所以说我们这边也做了一个评分管理的功能
那么入库可以自定义很多这样一些评分表
那么基于这个评分表可以生成一个打分
那么打分之后
我们需要进行跟踪了
这边有个跟踪产品的一个词字
你可以在这边进行一个词的构建
那么构建好之后
比如贯差词 和音词 白名单词
这些词都可以按照任何需求进行构建
构建好之后
可以把这个产品进行入词
这是一个跟踪词成关的词的汇总
那么在跟踪之后
比如说我们最终会形成下头了
我们就会形成一个投支持这样一个数据
那么投支持这个数据来源
是结合我们的一个
有限的自动化同步的功能
可以进行头后的一些数据规矩
数据汇总
比如说可以帮助我们用户分析一下
那么他所管这样一个负负产品的
这样一些规模的
这样一些统计的情况
以及说这些负负产品
那么他都有投什么底层
这些底层的这样一些策略分布的
一些持续或截面的一个走势
那这是一个头后的一个数据汇总
另外一个就是我们这边也有
做一个母金的这样一个列表
比如说我们打开我们的
在管产品列表
就能够看到说我们当前
所管这样一些资管负负
那么这些负负产品
最新的一个表现的情况
比如说净值
一些涨跌幅指标等这些情况
那么还有一个就是说
我们有一个负负底层
归基汇总的功能
那么结合我们这样一些
邮箱的一个数据同步
我们会自动化更新一下
那么我们的这些负负产品
都有投实木实木基金
每一个实木基金的这样一些
当前的这样一个总的
一个头寸的一个情况
包括说这个单一底层
那么它在不同负负里面
这样一个当前的这样一些持有的这样一个份额
持有这样一个市值
也就是说一些权重占比的这样一些数据的一个展示
那么这些数据都是属于我们的估值表更新
进行智能化规矩汇总
它不需要进行任何的一个手工的干预
那么十分的一个高效
那除此之外的话
就是我们的负负金领或研究员
那么他在投后可能需要不断的对我们的底层
进行一个估值表的这样一些拆解
那尤其是说比如说一些股票的
包括CT的
甚至说是一些期权的估值表
其实我们都能够做到比较好的
这样一些估值表的这样一些解析
解析好之后呢
我们就进行一些估值表拆解
那比如说对于CT的估值表
那么我们会把这样一些估值表里面
它所包含什么样的这样一些商品合约
估值合约
进行分板块的这样一些展示
那么这些合约
它对应的这样一些板块是什么
比如黑色有色能化农产
以及说每个板块的多空的
这样一些分布的情况
我们都可以按照这样按板块
按品种按多工的这样一些噶叉
进行一个分析
那么对于我们投入底层
如果是一个股票的一个估值表
我们也可以进行一个拆解
比如说我们拆解完之后
比如说这个某一个量化的一个
指针的一个估值表了
那么它可能持有2000支票了
那么这2000支票
那么它对应了这样一些
宽计的这样规模指数
一个市值占比的一个求和
那么它我们可以看它这样一些
呃
实际上的偏好
包括说我们可以把这2000支票
那么每一个票所对应的这样一个市值区间进行一个求和
来观测它一个市值的这样一些持股市值区间的一个分布情况
那后面还有就是有一些股票这样一些行业的分析
行业偏离度
包括说一些风险残口的计算
也就是说我们有了拜尔森的分割因子
我们可以把这个分割因子进行一个绩效归因
那么跟踪一下那么这个产品
那么跟一些对标基准
它这样一些分割因子的暴露
这样一个标准差的一个情况
那这是一个股票的一个估值表的分析
那另外一个就是我们在投后呢
可能需要进行相关这样一些风险监控
因为我们就像有了一些性质数据了
有了一些估值表的数据了
那么结合我们否共流平台所提供的
这样一些管理人这样一些预警信息
那么管理人这样一些相关这样一些
比如说证监会里面有没有一些处罚等这些措施
可以进行很多这样一些风险监控的这样一个内容
比如这边呢有个新疆预警
我们对于产品层面
我们可以进行相关这些指标的设置
比如说想设置一下
这样一些常见的
这样一些收益风险指标
像最大回撤
一些说一些不动率
等这些指标都可以进行一个监控
包括说某些产品
那么头后它的净值
可能是不能低于某个值
不能低于1.95了
或1.05这样子
那你也可以进行这样一些
净值的这样一些运营线
或止损线的一个监控
那另外就是我们
如果说有一些底层
是能够拿到这样一些估值表的话
我们针对于估值表
可以做很多更多的这样一些文章
像一些投资比例类的
投资诀类之类的
或者一些投资禁止类的事项
都可以进行这样一些
基于估值表这样一些监控的一些内容
那第二个监控预警
就是说这边有个管理人层面的预警
比如说我想监控一下
我们所持仓中的这样一些
负负底层管理人
我们对这些管理人
可以做一些学习信息的这样一些监控
比如说他的一些
有新触发一些诚信信息
或者说一些提示信息
包括一些管理规模变动
等这样的情况
都可以做一个
每日的一个监控
相对于管理人
这样的工商注册
如果说是有发生变更了
或者他的舆情
有一些负面舆情触发
或者被证监会
被一些派出机构
被一些交易所谴责
被一些税务
等这样一些
其他一些机构
进行相关这样一些
检测行的这样一些操作
我们也可以进行
每周这样一些
定时的一个监控
这是有要的管理人
相关这样一些风险监控的一个功能
那么后面一个菜单就是说
有一个运维这个大的一个菜单
因为伴随着你投资
那么这里面你币安是有很多数据
你需要进行一个不断的人工
或机器的一个整理的
那首先是这边有一个邮箱同步的功能
我们可以根据我们不同邮箱类型
可以选择
可以把我们这样一些在头后
那么收净值收估值表
这样的邮箱进行一个绑定
不同的邮箱类型
那么它这样操作可能不太一样
大家也可以看到我们这边的一个邮箱设置的一个教程
或者你可以联系我们的这样一个否不牛客户
来进行一个这样一些指导
帮助大家进行绑邮箱
那么绑完邮箱之后
其实我们这个抓取是一个十分五感的
我们差不多五到十分钟就会进行一个增量的抓取
可以抓取一下这些相关这样一些镜子数据
估值表数据
包括一些虚拟进制数据
这样一些数据
那么会把这些数据
形成我们公司内部的一套数据库
从而保证说
我们这个数据是仅限于内部可见的
它是不会对外进行一个公开展示的
那么大家也可以在旧次这边
有一个解析记录
来查看我们这样一些
邮箱的抓取的这样一些明细情况
那除此之外的话
就是我们在Fold投资中
其实还有很多数据
需要进行手工的这样一个维护的
比如说我们可能需要维护一些产品的这样一些要素
需要维护一些我们底层的这样一些申购书
或者这样一些台帐
或者说有些时候呢
我们可能需要用手工进行维护一些镜子
所以说我们这边也提供了一个镜子管理的功能
那你可以把管理员
比如说微信可能推送过来这样一个镜子的一个表格了
通过手工上传的方式
那么也可以把这个镜子进行上传
那么这个镜子它也同样是仅限于内部私有的一套镜子数据库
那么后方就是说
还有一个就是一个
报告的一套功能
是我们有定义了很多
这样一些报告的一个模板
那么你可以基于这个模板
进行报告这样一些输出
比如说我们可能每周
或者每个月
会去写一个这样一些
周报或者月报
发给我们这样一些投资人
或者一些合作机构
我们可以把这个模板预制好之后
接下来你只要每一周改变
改变一下这个一个
相关这样一些统计节点
就可以导出一个
比较精美的这样一些周报月报
这样一些格式了
那这是一个报告的一套功能
那后面还有之后
有一个分享的一套功能
因为很多否不应用用户
他们可能需要进行一个
数据的一个交流
比如说我们有一些性的数据
那么想对外进行一个展示了
分享给否不应用其他的用户
所以我们这边有做一个分享的功能
你只需要把这样一些
分享对象选择好
然后把这个对象
相关这样的手机号码输入之后
我们就会进行
自动化的一个数据
一个同步
预觅老师
我这边功能介绍大概是这些
那么整体来说的话
就是我们从一些市场数据的
一个相关这样一些指标的构建
包括说我们在投后
会作为很多这样一些投资汇总
风险控制
包括产品的运营数据
等这些功能点
基本上能够满足于
我们在发布投研之中
相关这样一些投研筛选
投中投后的一些更多分析
数据规律汇总
包括一些风险控制的
这样一些功能
大概是这些
看下各位老师
有没有其他一些问题
OK 感谢感谢蔡强老师
因为我刚刚听下来之后呢
然后呢我也有几个问题想跟您请教
然后待会小伙伴们大家有问题的话
也可以跟我一样
咱们可以上来提问
或者是在评论区提问都是可以的
那么其实我想问一下蔡老师
就是像其实咱们都知道
咱们火腐牛背后呢
其实依托于报复基金的管理经验
那其实包括最早咱们
其实这个是咱们自己内部用的系统
那就是能否请蔡湘老师
给咱们介绍一下
关于咱们火腹牛的
这样的一个发展历程
我们这套系统就开始是
在1718年的时候
当时我们几个股东之间
他们有成立相关这样一些
私募管理人
主要是做内部的这样一套
服务投资系统
所以当时觉得市场上
其他几家
比如像拍拍长等
可能更多的是一个
私募数据的一个展示
那么它比较缺乏
一些投资管理相关的
这样一些功能点
所以说我们
依托于我们自己的
一套IT团队
那么开发了这样一套
否不牛
我们在开发之后
其实刚开始
前面一两年
是主要是自动的一个状态
那么伴随着我们
整个公司的一个规模成长
以及说一些机构的推荐
大家发现说
我们这套系统
其实还挺好用的
比较贴近于我们
在做一些投资管理
做出一些经理评价
所以比其他一些平台是一个
可能更加觉得是一个
纯粹行业展示
而我们这边是围绕投后
去做的是比较深入的
所以说目前也是主要
目前的话也是
比较贴近于大家这样一些实战吧
那现在的话
我们整理了一个
付费的一些机构用户
基本上还是以
自来金融机构的这样一个
职管制营
或者是金融产品部为主
但用多少系统进行
一些头先筛选
头后这样一个分析功能
OK 明白
那像咱们是不是可以针对比如说像某个产品
它跟市场平均业绩水平做对比
比如说500指增
然后呢或者是说全市场量化选股等等
对的我们其实是提供了一个非常丰富的这样一套
进行评价的这样一些相关的这样一套功能
那比如说我们当你点开某个产品的时候呢
我们就有相关这样一些分析的模块
我们这边可以选择很多这样一些业绩基准
那么你可以从全网里面选择一些
比如说选择一些私募指数
可以做我们这样一些对标的基准
那么这样就是可以把
你当前的这个产品
跟这个策略的点赢指数
进行一个对比分析
就能够知道说
它里面有跑赢这样一套指数
可以做一个比较好的这样一套参考
包括多产品的时候
也是一样可以进行进行对比的
好的
那比如说像咱们
比如说在做产品组合的时候
是不是可以比如说导入第三方策略的静止
然后来做组合
同时呢再设定这个再平衡的周期呢
这个功能的话
其实我们这边也有进行一个开发了
就是我们在比如构建这样一个模拟组合的时候呢
我们可以选择相关这样一些基金
选择好基金之后
我们就可以进行相关这样一个组合的一个构建
OK好的好的
我大概了解了
感谢蔡强老师
那其他小伙伴们
大家如果有问题的话也都可以
就是机会难得
大家可以就是直接上来提问都是可以
或者是在评论区提问也是OK的
因为确实火腐牛
咱们我之前我自己也是自己有试用过
就真的是很多功能是很贴近
咱们在实际运用当中
就是功能都很实用
所以说大家可以就是今天趁着蔡强老师
然后做这样一场分享
然后大家就可以有问题
咱们就可以直接问
然后看看大家有没有什么问题
蔡总您好
我想问一下AI助手那边的功能
主要是有哪一些
最后变一个AI助手
那么AI助手目前主要是有三个方向
那么一个是说
帮助我们梳理一下
我们这样一些尽量报告
因为我们一般的话
比如说跟管理人尽量之后
可能会有一些录音
我们可以把这个录音丢到
我们的AI助手
我们可以结合这个录音
结合我们的一些尽量报告模板
帮助我们进行输出一个尽量报告
那另外一个应用就是说
我们这边有个台上助手
因为一些申购书的这样一个确认单
它一般是一个PDF的
所以说你可以手工进行传过来
我们可以帮你解决说
快速进行识别
可以录这个台上
把它录到我们的运营的台上里面去
那还有一个就是说
我们结合我们的这样一些知识库
我们可以进行这样一些
AI的这样问答
比如说帮你评价一下
那么某个管理人怎么样
某个产品怎么样
那这是三个运用
好的 谢谢
蔡老师我看到评论区
有小伙伴在问说
咱们的禁调的内容来源是什么
我们这边禁调的情况是这样的
就是我们这边的研究下面
有一个禁调报告
这个禁调报告的话
就来自于我们合作的
一些副管理人或者副分部
那么他们包括我们自己的
一些研究员
那么他们在写完
一些经济报告之后
如果说有一些
那么可以对外进行展示的
我们这边会把它收录过来
进行这样一些展示
目前的话
我们整体的报告的更新频率
还是挺高的
差不多每一周都大概有两三篇
这样子
那么策略覆盖维度
也包含了一些像CT股票的这边
包括一些指针套利
期权等各种策略都有覆盖到
OK好的
那比如说像蔡老师
像比如说咱们如果有的小伙伴
对于咱们这个平台比较感兴趣的话
那像如果说想了解一些
详细的使用方面的问题
在后期的话
咱们可以就是怎么样去
就是直接咱们去上官网联系吗
可以啊
就是我们如果说有一些群的话
我们就可以拉一下
或者直接官网里面联系
我们的客户也都可以进行开通
我们一般的话需要进行发一个名片
可能还需要做个认证之后
就可以开通试用了
OK好的明白了
对我主要是看今天很多小伙伴
大家也都还没有说
对OK
那刚刚有个小伙伴问说
目前能够覆盖多少管理人
目前的话
我们尽料这边的一些管理人
大概是有600多篇
就是说这个尽料报告
从我们更新以来
大概已经600篇
然后拭目尽职的话
就是我们目前大概覆盖了
有一千家管理人这样子
就是有每周或者每月
有一些稳态更新
这样一些拭目睛的数据
这样一些管理人
他也有一千家
OK好的
看看大家还有没有什么问题
小伙伴们
对大家可以上麦
直接直接提问
OK差不多
我看一下小伙伴们
如果还有问题的话呢
大家就可以上麦
直接问到咱们蔡老师
然后呢
蔡老师您好
我想问一下
咱们能够有什么好的办法
把一个模拟组合
转成实办组合吗
因为我有构建一个模拟组合
但是就是我有很多的调仓记录在里面
但我要把它变成一个石盘组合的话
我得怎么样能够快速的转换过去呢
目前的话就是我们在石盘组合这边
其实有提供了相关这样一套
批量上传的这样一些交易模板
那你可以根据这个交易模板整理好之后
可以把看到这个模板进行导出
然后进行一个整理之后把它导入进来
那那个我模拟组合那边
是不是也可以导出一个这样的文件呢
对模拟组合那边也可以导出类似这样一个文件
它交易率是可以导出的
只不过你导出之后
因为两者的一个计算逻辑
它们不太一样
所以说你需要进行一个微量的调整
不一样是一个是用累计进制算
一个是用单位进制算吗
对对这两个计算逻辑不太一样
那我要调
我要调哪个部分呢
您可以稍微说一下
就是调那个
就是您可以根据这个
比如说师范组合这边的一些交易记录
这边有一个我们的模板之后
把它打开之后
按照这个列
然后进行一个修改
比如说它那边可能不同列的位置不太一样
明白了
好的
如果有一些问题的话
到时候您可以联系一下我们的一些线上客户
到时候帮您去处理一下
好的
谢谢
OK
看看大家小伙伴们还有没有什么问题
对然后呢
如果说没有问题的话呢
咱们今天这场分享的话呢
可能就暂时先到这里了
那后期呢
这个
后期呢
这个回放的话呢
然后呢就会
我会这个叫
就是回放
我会后续放在咱们的这个
我的bilibili主页上
然后大家后期如果还想再重新看一次
也可以上平台上再看
好吧
那今天非常感谢蔡老师
然后呢也感谢大家的时间
然后呢希望今天这场分享能够给大家带来
嗯很实际的
就是在我们平时在构建整个配置上面
能够带来就是新的灵感
好吧非常感谢蔡老师
好的谢谢大家
OK好的好的
然后呢大家如果后续的话
想要了解到咱们火腐牛的话呢
然后具体呢可以上官网去联系
咱们这个平台的客服就可以了
好吗来谢谢大家
嗯好再见
再见 再见 蔡老师 再见